What are the main coach shocks
upon arrival in the United Kingdom,
either from Spain,
Latin America or any other part of the world
first I think what really shocks the most eh
to any foreigner,
even if it is someone from Northern Europe.
Um,
something 100x100 exclusively British,
is the fact of continually asking for forgiveness
for anything.
Here it says sorry,
sorry,
sorry eh,
even when eh.
you haven't really done anything
and someone bumps into you in the street,
you say sorry,
he says sorry to you
and it's like 1 loop of kindness.
It's all to avoid being rude.
Here's the best,
the greatest possible crime in this country is to be rude.
Another very difficult thing to understand when arriving here
is the kind of humor of the English.
The English do not laugh
eh to laugh,
not to make humor easy,
but it is always a mixture of sarcasm.
with irony and a lot of self-irony about his own country,
about his life.
So it's 1 pretty Dark mood,
quite intelligent,
but
hey,
it has that bully,
let's say sarcasm,
touch,
of messing with someone who makes it difficult to
eh understand it eh
when someone is
joking when he is serious,
The fact that the people here are not very direct,
that is,
if he wants to tell you something
eh bad,
I'm not going to tell you.
Honestly,
I will try to put 1 euphemism into it.
and 1 little sarcasm,
so it's supercomplicated from IR catching
any place
maintains a superclassic and antique aesthetic.
It could be from 1 supermarket to 1 bank.
They might look like Hogwarts or the Sex Education school,
but nothing could be further from the truth.
Are they places that are preserved
eh?
So on the outside,
potatoes,
restaurants too.
em eh maintain this wooden aesthetic eh?
Very very affordable
which contrasts on the other hand with another coaching
shock for many foreigners
here in the UK,
which is how digitized everything is,
that is,
em works almost entirely through em
there is hardly any in many cases,
do not deal with 1 worker.
There are 1 lot of surveillance cameras,
I think.
eh 1 camera for every 11 inhabitants or so eh?
But it contrasts 1 lot with
with this aesthetic
often eighties that they keep in everything else.
And it's something that I really liked.
from day 1,
in schools
it is mandatory to wear uniform until a certain age,
in adolescence,
in any type of public or private school.
This might not be 1 shock at all
for someone from Spain
or from anywhere in Europe,
eh?
But in the United Kingdom there is 1 social culture
around tea
and PAP,
specifically from consuming alcohol.
em is completely normal eh,
after work,
Go to the pub with your colleagues to have a look,
Some Paints in
is normal
smash your head drinking 1 pile
on weekends,
partying
is something very ingrained in Mexican culture,
eh?
especially in
in the culture of university students as well,
and it is something that for
for people from other parts of the world.
When they arrive here
or to other European countries
is something that they are very fond of.
Another thing that will surely be the case in Europe
we have just as assumed and that
can shock above all
to people coming from other parts of the world
eh,
it's the economics and and
normal that are some things here in the UK,
for example,
go out to eat eh,
have a drink at the pub em,
to have access to leisure and leisure facilities.
and sports infrastructures,
Go to the hairdresser's frequently,
I don't know,
buy 1 car
are things that are not considered 1 luxury
and that they can be allowed to
eh anyone with ease.
Cars for example are very cheap
even compared to the rest of Europe
for having the steering wheel upside down,
among other things.
But they are quite cheaper then eh
for example 1 car
that in another country in the world can be considered a 1 1 luxury,
it's hard to get here and see what it's like
simply 1 1 old thing
and to finish this first part eh.
The music that is often heard here
both on the radio and elsewhere
is almost always pop and rock
pop What about rock?
British,
American,
Canadians,
Australians,
do not leave much else
space for other musical genres,
or for other languages,
much less talk about reggaeton
who do not even know what it is